non à l'austérité et au pression
managériale c'est le message des
postiers du département réunis ce matin
devant la direction du courrier à
montigny dans le viseur un principe
celui de la sécabilité pour les facteurs
c'est à dire le partage des tournées
lors de l'absence d'un collègue
sécabilité elle est venue il ya quelques
années quand il manquait du personnel
les postiers temps une grande famille eh
bien on se partageait la tournée du
copain qui était absent pour une maladie
ou quelque chose on appelait ça joliment
la marguerite ils ont intégré ça dans
leur réorganisation est aujourd'hui
c'est devenu monnaie courante c'est à
dire que dans la semaine il ya des
tournées qui ne sont pas faites et
reprise par petits bouts sur les agents
qui sont présents donc du travail
supplémentaire qui n'est pas payé
évidemment donc ça c'est du travail
dissimulé ça on peut pas l'accepter les
salariés réclament des embauches mais
aussi de meilleures conditions de
travail pour sept agents de collecte au
centre de tri de bois d'arcy depuis 2005
les techniques de management sont
directement responsables du mal être des
salariés là bas effectivement je levais
un jeu des demandes d'explication parce
que on est une minute en retard ou parce
qu'on va fumer une cigarette entre entre
deux camions voyez il ya pour aller pour
aller aux toilettes il faut presque
donné presque demander l'autorisation
voilà il ya eu des suppressions
d'emplois dues à des problèmes des
conseils de discipline dus à des
problèmes
le rassemblement local a rejoint la
manifestation nationale organisée à
paris quelques heures plus tard en
france et dans les yvelines la
participation atteignait les 5 % mais
dans le département le taux s'est élevé
à limay par exemple jusqu'à 90% selon
les syndicats 61% selon la direction
celle ci n'a pas souhaité répondre à nos
questions